اذا حط الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي
لنسكي في حاطه ريحانه في واشنطن في الرحله
الخارجيه الاولى له من انطلاع الحرف في
بلاده قادما من بولندا علمتني طائره
امريكيه تابعه للرئاسه بهدف حمايته من اي
استهداف زنسكي كان كتب في منشور على تويتر
قائلا في طريق الى الولايات المتحده
لتعزيز صمود اوكرانيا وقدراتها الدفاعيه
خصوصا ساناقش مع الرئيس التعاون بين
بلدينا كما سالقي كلمه في الكونجرس واحضر
عددا من الاجتماعات الثنائيه غادر الرئيس
الاوكراني بلاده الى بولندا المجاوره
ومنها انطلق نحو الولايات المتحده فما هو
معلوم ان لا يطا يران مدنيا يمر عبر
السماء الاوكراني التي يصدها ضجيج
الطائرات الحربيه والصواريخ
[موسيقى]
ملفات اساسيه مطروحه على طويله الرئيسيين
سيعلن خلالها الرئيس الامريكي عن حزمه
جديده من المساعدات الامريكيه الاضافيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه ملياراي دولار تشمل
منظومات للدفاع الجوي وقنابل دقيقه موجهه
للطائرات المقاتله وفق مستشار الامن
القومي
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
فاعلن ان الولايات المتحده ستقدم حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه اضافه الى مليار و850
مليون دولار
وستزودك في منظومه صواريخ الاكثر تطورا
للدفاع الجوي القادر على اسقاط صواريخ
كروز وصواريخ بالستيه قصيره المدى زياره
القادمه
[موسيقى]
فردوسيات كل هذا بالطابع سيؤدي الى تفاقم
الصراع وهذا واقع لا يبشر بالخير
لاوكرانيا